dwayne johnson just gave this super
sweet interview about like how great you
are with his kids and this friendship
you guys have what is it about your
friendship that's so special what's it
like for you too oh it's just like two
dads so i don't know i really don't
think of it as like
it's really cool where you know even the
same thing with hemsworth you just or
you're
you just kind of go like you're just
buds i'll see you soon okay
happy third birthday hi jessie
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah i don't really think it was like
the rock's caller duane's calling just
like
he's duke his
your buds and also i feel like he's
doing a lot of good things for the
planet he's a good father
and um and i'm equally trying to do the
same i've been having dreams
about a girl on a ruckus
i don't know what it means
dreams make good stories
but everything important happens when
we're awake
hey you put on some muscle i did
no let me tell you i guess some i'm sure
you've heard this a million times today
but this movie is so freaking good and i
left the theater wanting the sequel
right here right now it was the greatest
experience working on this i can't
believe i'm even in this movie it's
amazing to even be a part of this and
then work with
my idol so denise
my favorite director in the world and
then you get to work with javier brolin
oscar
this movie this incredible movie that is
like
i just can't wait for it to see the best
part is like you've seen it once i've
seen it three times the third time was
better i mean they're all different
experiences they're truly watching the
cinema
on that level and we're only watching
half the movie you've done a lot of
training for a lot of different
characters over the years what was the
training like for this one because your
fight scenes are so beautiful and
incredible
i never fought that many people at once
so i mean i think it all goes down too
and also i have a wonderful stunt man
um who
you know
protects me and then also helps train me
and then we have
the step teams generally
at this level are
amazing so
on this just making sure we don't hurt
anyone like really it's just training
and training training so you want to
protect the stuntman and
their job is to protect me and i want to
protect them so it's just really like
giving your all to
i feel like i always ask you this but
like who wins duncan or cal drogo
well probably duncan cause he's got the
whole right here he can just put up the
whole uh
shield the shield like he's gonna you
know
struggle's gonna be like what the hell
why can't i kill him i just got a shield
on so
anna
you know i was i mean i've been a fan of
yours since game of thrones and am i
doing my research i realized it's been
10 years since got premiered and i was
kind of getting a little emotional today
looking at your imdb page and thinking
in 10 years man i mean game of thrones
and being a superhero and now working in
this movie with denis and premiering at
venice like
how do you feel thinking about
everything you've done in the past
decade and being here it is
it is crazy i haven't really looked back
and had time to i just kind of put my
head down and go go because
before that 10 years before that
i tried to put food on the table you
know before game of thrones happens like
everyone i'm just literally trying to
get jobs of trying to audition to get
jobs i don't necessarily want but i'm
just trying to become an actor
and then finally i'm here my favorite
director calls me
and asks me to play it like he's
pitching me
i don't even believe it what lesson does
that teach you
everything you do in life
will ripple out she should be a good
human do your job really well because
obviously at some point
you know someone will see you but you
just stick to your
i i wish i would have stressed out as
much that i still do i think that's just
my job because we're just going to dad
so
i would probably live a lot longer if i
didn't stress out so much about
you having a job but now it's like it's
just
i don't know i'm just very i try to be
really humble thankful for it being 10
years since got you guys have a reunion
in the works or anything listen i just
met up with everybody dave and dan are
here for truly two still two of my best
friends and uh they're shooting their
own show here i don't we definitely get
together a lot but um
you
know i'm dead as dead if you get but
it's pretty cool man i mean i think if
there's one thing we all see about you
from your social media and everything
it's that you're a family guy and to
hear you just say look i was trying to
put food on the table and now to think
about what an incredible success you are
for your family that's pretty amazing
thank you